reason I was bringing up the whole anime
thing right right because it's because I
watched my first anime recently properly
that was Dragon Ball Z Pokemon yu-gios
TV on the morning cartoons you know yeah
but I never actually like watched them
because okay that was a [__] but I
watched my first anime and I was very
proud of myself uh Alex behind the
camera's been trying to convince me for
a very long time what's your attack on
Titan
Fortnight
Captain Captain Levi's uh he's the goat
yeah um and I was just like yeah I just
wanted to share that I watched my first
anime so thank you oh yeah how'd you
feel ah no it was sick um I think even
still because I watched uh I watched the
subtitle version that's what I've told
was the most authentic way yeah yeah
um
like where did my girlfriend out a
little bit because there's a lot of
grunting and stuff like like ah I like
the like this like delay it's just like
money that was a meme it's actually a
word I didn't know that
it's my ignorance uh it's ignorant right
but it means
yeah I I I slowly figured out that when
they were saying Nani like what was
showing up
um but that was cool that was a cool
thing for me to skip I thought it was
just a meme
yeah yeah yeah it was just like everyone
would edit into their videos
I got you oh my God but it's just like
there's so much like even an attack on
Titan not so much the later Seasons but
there's still so much wasted time I
think in anime so there is an old TV not
fortnite brain I think yeah oh yeah no
I'm a tick-tocks
how is time wasted in it explain they
just spend a lot of time just like
repeating the same [__] or like just
talk about stuff that I don't think
matters but maybe it's good for like
World building or some [__] but I'm like
are you called up on the second time
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't read it
though Alex knows what happened yeah was
it was it it was a lot of it confusing
as well because Attack on Titan is a
weird story no I was I've got it from
start all right okay no no I mean it was
It was obviously just like keeps
throwing [__] at you yeah all of a
sudden everything he thought was real
[__] wrong everything thought was
real wrong it just like keeps changing
the game on you which I thought was
really cool yeah like it just kept
changing the scope it was getting bigger
bigger bigger bigger yeah well I think
Attack on Titan is probably like in my
opinion arguably the best starter anime
Attack on Titan is way better than that
in terms of like well that was the thing
I was gonna ask is like what should you
watch what's what's next I've been told
demon Sawyer but um I wanna honestly
like get a top five of what I should do
next in terms of starter animate
chainsaw man yeah actually actually
before before we get into this what kind
of like TV shows do you like or movies
oh I'm a very broad spectrum uh person
in that regard I don't think I have any
the only thing I don't like is horror um
okay I'm a massive coward scariest movie
I've ever watched with Scary Movie one
um I was like six or seven when I first
watched it and I thought the scream mask
was from that originally yeah
Okay and like that scene was like a dick
that goes through someone's ear or some
[__] oh yeah yeah no okay
oh yeah yeah so yeah I don't like horror
uh otherwise pretty open to anything
well luckily anime isn't that great I
mean Attack on Titan gets pretty [__]
wild that's that's probably a little bit
more gory than horror yeah that's a bit
more violent Glory than horror but yeah
anime generally doesn't do horror well
so that's that's a good thing for you it
does it by accident well something yeah
okay yeah there's a lot of things that
are horrific but not hey actually there
are somewhat pretty like scary scenes in
Attack on Titan oh yeah exactly God I
just remember like remembering the first
scene remembering seeing that first
Titan oh yeah like okay can we I mean I
don't know you allowed to like talk
about it yeah yeah let's talk about it
well this way and his [__] mum gets
eaten yeah yeah yeah horrified yeah I
had no context what this show was about
yeah everyone's just like watch Attack
on title man okay I'm like okay anime
can't be that metal right that hardcore
it is yeah I thought May Beauty like
sword fighting like gory in that yeah
this man like you're witnessing
childhood trauma like actual real yeah
credit to the people that animated and
stuff because like you see like lifelong
damage being imprinted in this kid as
his mother is slowly dramatically
chomped in half and it turns out it's
his [__] stepmom that did it or
whatever it was yeah yeah it's like his
father's previous wife or some [__] so
what the [__] yeah what oh my God yeah I
just I remember the first time seeing
like because Attack on Titan [__]
blew up when it uh first aired from
episode one and just seeing that first
like smiling Titan like the one that
eats Aaron's mom that was like nightmare
fuel you know yeah especially if you see
as a kid also the like the muscles on
the butt cheeks of the Colossal type
that was traumatizing man you saw every
fiber in that gluteus squats bro yeah
100 is it traumatizing maybe maybe it
was a different kind of thing I I think
you'd like death note I think Death Note
you'd like a lot all right yeah everyone
knows that Alex track these for me
please remind me later death note I feel
Death Note is like not I wouldn't say
it's like the best uh Gateway anime
because unlike attack on time that's
like especially season one where it's
like very easy to understand very easier
because there's a lot of like high
intense action that anyone can get into
it's a lot more like mental and like
psychological battles rather than like
actual physical fights which I think is
like you know no I think I think I think
Death Note is great like the only the
most physical they get death note is
when Ellen light play tennis yeah like I
still think it's a good start around
mate okay it is but it's a different
flavor yeah right like it's I feel it's
a different side of anime that okay you
know it very much exists and it's still
great what do you look like Attack on
Titan off the top of your head what are
some of your favorite movies oh
Monty Python Holy Grail
a free guy because I'm in it
I don't know like see I consume so much
stuff but like [__] if I everywhere
everything all at once Banger
um I had no idea what that movie was
before I saw it but we went to like some
early screening thing before it blew me
away
um yeah I don't know I don't know if I
have like any sort of genre or any type
of thing that like I'm very like average
ass human being in that regard where I
just did love Death Note okay
Brotherhood it's pretty good because
it's very anime I think the first yeah
the first anime I heard of that like I
knew people were watching years ago was
full metal album I think it's been rated
by anime fans like the best anime okay
yeah I'm not watching something that's
got more than like a hundred episodes if
it's like one of those like is it one
piece has got like a thousand yeah one
thing's got not doing that yeah yeah
that's doable that's fun yeah I say
chainsaw man would be pretty good if you
liked it Attack on Titan because that's
only 12 episodes yeah
is very horny there's already so much
grunting how much more horny
right I'm gonna be real like my
girlfriend thought I was watching
something she's like walking in like
what is happening you're in the living
room bro the windows anime that was like
uh a guy who just reviewed brothels in
another universe that was like an animal
what's that one called into species
reviewers yeah uh yeah don't uh don't
know one of your girlfriend in the uh
okay what point does it go from animal
uh anime to hand time
I mean the one where they review
brothels there's literally just a sex
scene okay in it where one of them sleep
with one of the girls in the brothel
yeah and it's just it's all there it's
fully present and it goes on for like
five minutes or something so we don't
actually know what the line between
that's like an interesting thought I
feel that like I've never had a little
finishing that line further and further
further there's no point where it's like
oh it's I don't even know what it is
anymore
tentacle or no tentacle is that the line
for well see because like this I don't
know anything I mean again
no no because there's a lot of anime and
a lot of hentai that uses tentacles but
like it's the difference between like
how it is
I guess utilized okay right because it's
like there's a lot of like very innocent
scenes that use tentacles but like it's
the implication of it might be construed
as something sexual but it's not
adherently sexual because that's that's
my ignorance to unfortunately this like
whole sort of like I guess communities
like I've never really part-took so I
only see the memes yeah sure
um I mean it definitely exists there's a
lot of it I've got I've got some stuff
to watch now you should watch JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure as well you ever heard
of that one no oh you probably like that
I'm sorry it's like a whole world that
I've just I I it was always one of those
things I never wanted to give up to my
friends that like they always ask me to
watch anime I was like this is one of
those things where I'm putting the Line
in the Sand
just cause like [__] you you're asking
too much
it's like a personality trait I don't
watch anime arcane
nice uh I don't know what the [__] that
is what is it Arcane it was the League
of Legends oh [__] League of Legends
God you don't like Leo I never play
League of Legends I play one game of doe
and I was like this shit's stupid well
yeah I agree yeah but what's the
difference they're Moses big big
difference big difference yeah no but
I'm I'm still I'm very much in the same
like field as Yolanda where it's like if
people around me are continuously like
shoving it down my throat being like
watch it watch it watch it it just makes
me not want to watch it yeah yeah no
definitely I hate it but I look after
watching Attack on Titan I go watch that
in like the space for like four or five
days or something so I just went through
it all uh that was a lot of episodes
that's like attack before like four
seasons grinding bro
it was definitely within a week man I
guarantee you you're yeah I I actually
do recommend Death Note like you want
good I'm excited
chainsaw chains if chainsaw man's only
12 episodes that's an easy one oh yeah
you'll fly by like I think the reason
why death is such a good start anime is
because right out of the gate it's just
[__] intense no like you get hooked
within the first two episodes that's
important I don't like [__] it takes me
like a whole season or something yeah
that's that's kind of like yeah they'll
fix the [__] tickets you might have
mention it in there but what's your
favorite animes is this like a debatable
topic that like it gets heated here not
really just because we watch so many
that like my favorite anime changes all
the [__] times I like that mentality
you know it's kind of like asking what
your favorite game is and I'm like well
I have you can say some of your
favorites that's yeah that's fair or is
it in that watch list already yeah
because of the brothel one
hey man safe place here man yeah yeah I
don't know I mean I'd say like the one
that I usually say to anyone who asks
that question is probably like fully
coolly because that's like that's also a
good show I think to watch because it's
like it's hipster it's wild as hell and
it's only six episodes and it is just
intense from start to finish but
something completely unique as well I
like that yeah I feel like that was the
one thing even just saw Attack on Titan
it felt like a story that they are I'm
going to tell in some other sort of
medium yeah even just like like they
just you can't make that I think they
did try to make a live action attack oh
yeah I heard it I saw someone's like a
clip of my Tick Tock someone's saying
this is the worst thing ever I love
Hunter Hunter which is great
um animation is great I got I got a
pitch I don't recommend you watch this
immediately okay but maybe maybe okay I
mean I mean I'm excited
oh this has got me more excited what's
going on it's so faint
perfect
I got my Crunchyroll subscription I can
watch yeah specifically Fate Zero okay
um so it's a battle royale so
it is a battle royale anime where uh a
bunch of wizards and mages they summon
like a legendary hero from history to
fight for them that's sick so I love
that like got like Genghis Khan away
yeah yeah yeah so you know use the
people summon like King Arthur
um is an anime waifu in this yeah anime
what King Arthur is a girl yeah
Alexander the Great
um that's the first book I ever read was
about Alexander the Great yeah so a
bunch of like Legendary Heroes from
history and they just [__] battle it
out and it's a mix between like action
and just Mind Games as well uh because
everyone's like playing chess with each
other trying to like you know trying to
knock each other out which sounds so
much better than it is yes
to be fair face hero is [__]
fantastic yeah the reason why I was
screaming no is because the problem is
that after you watch Fate Zero there's a
whole other bunch of series and
spin-offs and it becomes one of the most
complicated fictional universes
let's just leave it there you watch Fate
Zero and just leave it at that you can't
yeah for sure would I want to afterwards
that's the problem if you get too into
it then you'll be like well what else is
Fate Stay no it's pretty good yeah I'd
say well yeah I'd say like if you
watched if you just Watch Fate Zero and
unlimitably works that's you could
probably understand like 90 of the
unlimited works is good yeah but like if
you want to feel the remaining 10 then
you have to watch like all these other
like spin-off shows and sequels and
prequels and it gets way too there's a
lot of really dark shows as well you
might I don't know do you like more
serious shows
um probably not really I don't like to
feel things I have to go main uh I like
to go brain dead and just be like damn
that's [__] [__] yeah